we're about to watch our little family
which follows the everyday lives of the
hamel family who happen to be little
people and i'm joined today by the
lovely pamela ray schuler i'm a comedian
keynote speaker and disability advocate
huge thank you to google for sponsoring
a portion of this video let's get
started
we are a family of five and what makes
us so special is that we are all small
we're raising our kids to know life can
be just as good small as it is tall i
remember the last time i lost my tooth
to you
no i put it under the pillow
and then my dad's like i'm not giving
you any money and i said what about the
tooth fairy though
he said we're russian immigrants
what up hamilton have you seen this show
no neither i'm in it i'm into it not in
it oh i was gonna say you're in it
we have twin daughters and they are
about to turn three their names are cece
and kate and they are the complete
opposite of jack they are very high
maintenance that's like you i agree
fully which is why the twins are my
favorite people already what's unique
about our family is that we are all
small and that we all have the most
common form of dwarfism which is
achondroplasia achondroplasia you've
heard of it yes achodroplasia is when
you have a defect in changing cartilage
into bone because when we're born we
actually have a lot of cartilage that
needs to ossify aka turn into bone those
who have achondroplasia have normal size
torsos usually and then have shorter
than normal limbs
upper and lower that makes sense so i'm
four foot six and a half so i'm of short
stature but i don't have a specific
diagnosis like any kind of pleasure i
really think i just forgot to grow okay
well that happens i'm little my kids are
little i'm very proud to be a little
person
we'll all little together i think
there's like a lot of these views that
people with disabilities and differences
are like sitting home sad and wishing
our differences away in addition to
being four foot six and a half five
tourette syndrome and i think for a lot
of us we've embraced the heck out of
what makes us us and personally i don't
wish to not be different but i do
sometimes wish that the world was
created a little bit more with
disabilities and differences in mind
jack just started kindergarten and he's
riding the bus with all the other kids
because we don't want him to feel any
different is there any dangers that i
don't see any dangers no you know i will
say though the development of children
who are born with achondroplasia there's
an issue with where the brain stem turns
into the spinal cord it's called the
cervical medullary junction can
sometimes be more narrow so when you
pick up a child that has achondroplasia
diagnosis you need to be careful and
really support the back of their head oh
so that it doesn't go back because they
could have injury no one should let me
hold kids without like just at all when
two little people have kids they have a
50 chance that the baby will be little
then we have a 25 chance that the baby
will be average size then we have a 25
chance that the baby will inherit the
dwarfism gene from both of us and if the
baby inherits that gene from both of us
they call it a double dominant baby and
after it's born it doesn't live very
long in medical textbooks it usually
says someone who is homozygous for this
condition is incompatible with life
um i would say there's a possibility
that they can be born and sustain life
early on but then they usually
end up passing same day that i found out
that i was pregnant with twins i also
found out that i had a medical
complication that there was a blood clot
in the middle of the two babies blood
clot in the middle of the two babies i'm
guessing in the umbilical vein that's
really rare they had told me that if
that blood clot were to break within my
first trimester i could lose either one
or both of those babies in general
pregnancy creates a higher risk for
having blood clots that's a known risk
but having twins elevates that risk even
more
specifically later in the pregnancy
luckily we were blessed that the babies
got bigger and the blood clot got
smaller but then we had to test to see
if they had the double dominant gene
first we found out that cece was going
to be little and a girl just sweet that
maybe that's the most important and then
we knew that she was healthy and it was
going to be a girl do you
think about or care about
if you have a child what their height is
going to be no i'd be more afraid that
they'd be athletic like i can raise i
can raise a kid of any height i can
raise a kid with tourette's but like
what am i gonna go to a basketball game
well you can watch it's really common
for little people to have a fear of dogs
[Laughter]
i wonder how they'd feel about bear bear
we're best friends hi high five
oh yes you can get the whole body yeah
oh can i get one too bud oh thank you
can i get one thank you buddy can i get
one one more high five he's like daddy
please just one more high five my turn
oh
you're a traitor you're my best boy
you're a traitor advertised people
really don't think about it but imagine
if
dogs were the size of bears and they
were coming up to you did she say size
of bears back to the show in just a
second but first i want to thank google
for sponsoring this portion of the video
accessibility is incredibly important to
all humans as we've seen on the show as
i've seen with my patients and as pam
has seen in her everyday life pam why is
accessibility so important well as
someone with a neurological movement
disorder and of short stature
accessibility is my access to the world
when i can access the world i can bring
my best self to my community i was
actually really hyped when google
approached me with this partnership
because they take accessibility
seriously on all android devices google
actually has these features that i think
are revolutionary the one that interests
me the most is the live transcribed one
where if you're having a conversation
with someone who's deaf or hard of
hearing it actually creates live
captioning that's really accurate i'm
obsessed with voice access uh i think a
lot of times the media likes you to
think that tourette's is just like
yelling words but for me it primarily
manifests itself through movements and
for me i have almost no control over my
hands that's what i use i speak into my
phone and it's able to capture what i'm
saying and the one that uh i think pim
and i both really enjoy and we probably
use like regularly is the accessible
places feature which when you search on
google maps you actually get information
about how accessible a certain location
could be these features are incredible
yeah i mean we want to have a more
inclusive world it's happening right in
front of our eyes with this technology
again huge thank you to google for
sponsoring this portion of the video
let's get back to our show does he carry
a stool
because you used to have a stool from
first grade through i mean eighth grade
i live in a studio apartment in new york
city and i have six stools in one
apartment i can't reach my microwave
because in new york they put them above
your oven stove whatever that thing is
in my closet i can't reach eighty
percent of it i have a stool there i
wanted my bathroom because most of the
storage is above the sink in my living
room i've got one because my bed is a
normal size that i have to run and jump
into it and sometimes you don't want to
be an acrobat today we are meeting
jack's teacher and to be honest i'm not
exactly sure what she's going to say
does he ever like sit there and go oh
mrs claiborne i can't see he told the
boys and girls you guys need to move
over because i cannot even do the
rectangle rumba so he moved himself to
the front and stood right in front of
that is it self-advocacy yeah i love
that i think that's something we should
be working with all kids not just kids
with disabilities and differences like
how do you how do you speak up if you're
not getting what you need to be
successful i talk a lot about disability
inclusion but in reality we all need
different things at different times to
be successful you have to be this high
so you can go to the left jack i think
and then i think the girls need to go to
the right it's the same thing it goes to
the same place at the bouncy pillow we
had to make a decision do we send jack
with people his own age or do we send
him with the people his own size it's
saying by height yes so why are we
trying to create a new interpretation
because i also he might want to play
with his friends fair the reason i worry
about this and the reason i'm being
strict about it is because if you're
like in an amusement park and there's
these signs about height yeah because of
safety and security of the seat belts
and locking that i get it i can't ride
half of those rides really i'm too short
to ride house i can't either because of
my fear
why are you laughing at me sorry that's
not fair you made it sound like you
can't for like an accessible reason that
is an accessible reason it's a mental
health reason that's accessible okay
fine can we have some cookies
thank you so much i'm living in an
average-sized world it's not gonna adapt
to me i have to figure out how to adapt
to the world how about these look
come here why don't we do these my
grocery store in new york city refers to
me as the climber at one point they were
like you have to stop climbing and i was
like okay then you either need to have
step stools that are available to me or
have someone who is available to reach
the things down because in new york we
build up yeah and so i can't reach
70 of the things i need at a grocery
store so what did they say to you they
told me they would have someone help me
and i still climb yeah
because i was just born small
because we were both born small i love
that about children that they're not
afraid they're just being genuine i
think that's the most authentic and
genuine way to go about it i agree kids
have questions because they're learning
about the world and if we shush a kid
when they have questions we're teaching
them to feel shame in the presence of
disability so while not everyone is
comfortable explaining to a kid maybe
why they're
little or why they twitch or why they
use a wheelchair um for people who are
it's great because we're giving
kids information and kids i think are
inclusive when they get it whenever i'm
more
honest about what i don't know
and what i can learn
the more engagement i get i wish more
doctors did that i wish more scared like
i don't actually know a lot about
tourettes can you tell me bam if you put
me in a room with 10 000 people who are
four foot six and a half and have a
whole lot of tourette syndrome every
single one of us would have a totally
different story it'd be cool to build
one sometime in our yard or something
that would be
a place on totally equal grounds like
just design it so he doesn't know it's
any different but he could
climb up as fast as the other kids or
whatever you know you mean for you to
build it yeah
wow
disrespectful laugh i love that like
yeah this show's about a family of
little people but it's also just about
like a family yeah and they are they
talk smack that was like a sick burn
the challenge of building this playset
is i have to make things space a little
bit closer together project i also want
to space in a way that every other kid
in the world can use it too and it's not
exclusively for him great example of
universal design universal design is
this idea that as we create anything a
building a community a structure a phone
a tool we create it with the goal of as
many people as possible being able to
use it as the at the fullest extent
possible okay so really example of that
besides this when you go to open a door
and there's a button and the door opens
automatically that was initially
designed for people who use wheelchairs
but think about someone carrying
groceries think about someone carrying
kids think about someone who maybe
doesn't have use of their hands or arms
you do something for one or two and it's
often beneficial for so many more i was
born and raised in annapolis i have
never really left i stay here because no
one sees me as a little person anymore
michelle describe them i just heard
that's it's just an interesting way to
i think
i'm trying to figure out like the best
way to say this
i think it's okay to see disability she
is of short stature she's a little
person i think what she probably means
or i'm never going to put points in her
mouth
don't treat her differently yeah that's
what i think probably like i think i
don't of course i think i actually don't
love it when someone is like when i'm
with you pam i don't see tourette's
anymore
i bark
like yes i take advantage of that when
i'm with you
bush yes
some average days people think that
little people can't work out and that's
a total myth dude you work out harder
than me except when i'm boxing training
for a professional fight i'm doing a lot
more but otherwise your baseline of
working out is insane thank you i love
working out and the gym is made for men
of average height the elliptical i was
told i'm too short to use i'm too short
to use any of the bikes the things that
you pull down i can't even reach it
as a little person i'm really lucky that
i don't have any physical complications
that cause me not to be able to do what
i physically like want to do those with
achondroplasia have higher rates of
osteoarthritis so they can have a lot of
joint pain and it can be very painful
also those with achondroplasia
especially kids have higher rates of
frequent middle ear infections
uh early development of sleep apnea huh
there's so there's things you have to
what we call our medicine is give
anticipatory guidance that's interesting
i've had a ton of ear infections and no
one ever told me it could be connected
to something else see if i was your
doctor and you weren't patient okay i'll
just cut yours okay
oh my god i love him he's going for this
that's how i eat a man of my heart we're
gonna start eating healthier
maybe tomorrow since we're eating pizza
tonight the story of my life maybe
tomorrow i really want the kids to have
better eating habits because as little
people if you're overweight it's more
pressure on your knees
your joints and your back you know what
point we never made clear medically
about this if you're born with
achondroplasia there's no other medical
conditions that you're diagnosed with
you still have a normal life expectancy
oh that's good to know michelle's taking
a cooking class the girls are taking
dance
made me kind of realize that there's
something i've wanted to do for a long
time what do you guess that he's gonna
do
what i hope it is is like a magic class
i was looking up skydiving oh i kind of
signed myself up
you're gonna go
skydiving right there see look his
parachute open i'm so relieved dan's
parachute opened that was my biggest i
guess that is the thing that you want
there's your little boy
hey jack
my dad can do anything yeah
do you know that pam roasts me literally
all the time she actually roasted my
entire instagram picture catalog click
here to check that out as always stay
happy and healthy and
fabulous you said nuggety i know i
switch it up okay
[Music]